ahora que tenemos un conocimiento básico
acerca de las razones tratemos de
resolver problemas más complejos
tenemos un salón de clases con 55
estudiantes
y sabemos también que la razón la razón
de niños de niños y niñas lo indicó esta
manera es de 4 a 7 y lo que quiero saber
es cuántas niñas
cuántas niñas
tengo que agregar lo podría poner lo
necesito necesito
agregar
para necesito agregar para que la razón
sea necesito agregar para que la razón
sea de 1 a 2 y seguimos considerando que
esté la razón de niños a niñas no se ha
invertido esto para nada
actualmente las razones de 4 niños por
cada 7 niñas y lo que quiero hacer es
agregar algunas niñas para que la razón
sea de un niño por cada dos niñas cómo
hacemos esto bien si recordamos el
primer vídeo sobre razones conocemos que
hay 55 estudiantes y sabemos que la
razón es de 4 a 7 quizás nos ayude a
saber cuántos niños y niñas hay
actualmente así es que la razón actual
es de 4 a 7 la razón de niños y niñas
actualmente es de 4 a 7
eso significa si sumamos estas 2 si
sumamos estas 2 tenemos que por cada
por cada 11 estudiantes por cada 11
estudiantes por cada 11 estudiantes
tenemos cuatro niños y siete niñas hay
cuatro niños
siete niñas eso es lo que nos da esta
razón si este salón de 55 estudiantes lo
dividimos en grupos de 11 estudiantes en
cada uno de ellos va a haber cuatro
niños y siete niñas es lo que nos da
esta razón si separamos en grupos
homogéneos de 11 estudiantes vamos a
obtener siempre cuatro niños y siete
niñas ahora cuántos grupos de 11
estudiantes hay bueno si tenemos 55
estudiantes y queremos dividirlos en
grupos de 11 estudiantes es decir 55
estudiantes queremos repartir los en 11
grupos más bien queremos dividirlos en
grupos de 11 estudiantes entre 11
estudiantes por grupo
así es que 55 estudiantes divididos en
grupos de 11 estudiantes cuánto nos va a
dar nos va a dar 55 entre 11 5 grupos 5
grupos de 11 estudiantes y como ya
sabemos cada grupo tiene 4
y siete niñas de tal manera que en cada
uno de estos cinco grupos hay cuatro
niños por lo cual hay en total cinco por
cuatro igual a veinte niños y siete
niñas en cada uno de los cinco grupos es
decir en total cinco por siete que es
igual a 35 niñas 35 niñas y todo cuadra
20 35 es igual a 55 y la razón de 20 a
35 es la misma razón de 4 a 7 nuestros
cálculos son correctos eso es lo que
tenemos actualmente y lo que queremos es
aumentar el número de niñas en el salón
para cambiar la razón hagamos eso
así es que actualmente tenemos 20 niños
y 35 niñas es el número que calculamos
de niños y niñas que tenemos en el salón
y queremos agregar un número x de niñas
a ese salón y queremos agregar x niñas
al salón para que la razón de niños a
niñas sea ahora de 1 a 2 tenemos ahora
una ecuación con un incógnita que hay
que resolver aunque esta ecuación la
podemos resolver mentalmente 20 es aquel
número como uno es a 2 más fácil si uno
es la mitad de 2 entonces 20 es la mitad
de 40 así es que esto tiene que ser 40
con lo cual x tiene que ser igual a 5
bueno y si no lo que es el mentalmente
lo conoce algebraica mente podemos hacer
la multiplicación cruzada de los
denominadores 35 + x por 1 es igual a 35
más x y esto es igual a 2 por 20 40 que
es el resultado que obtuvimos
mentalmente cuando razonamos que 35 x
tiene que ser igual a 40
así es que restando 35 ambos lados
obtenemos que x es igual a 5 por lo que
al agregar 5 niñas al salón vamos
en total 40 niñas y al tener 20 niños la
razón va a ser de 20 a 40 o 24 o lo que
es lo mismo 1 a 2 y así hemos concluido